I want you to look at the photo again
look at my time zero snapshot okay
because right now i'm working in my in
the time universe okay so i've got i
want functions of time because if I know
the time equals zero i can substitute
anything that I know he are like like
say this okay i can substitute them into
any of my equations in terms of time and
get something meaningful out ok now
we've already accounted for the fact
that the cars velocity is this at a
certain time what else in this picture
am I being told what other kinds of
quantities okay so i can go to the truck
and i promise you i will but i am not
done yet here's also these distances
here right I know about where the car is
ok or i can define where the cars so
that means i need to integrate again ok
so just pause from it why am I
integrating I'm trying to take into
account this information that we've got
here ok if I'm going to talk about the
trucks displacement which I will I have
to be able to compare it to the cars
displacement I might as well deal with
all the car equations first then move on
so therefore integrating again
of course we notice that the varsity of
the car is DX on dt follow the car so
i'm going to say the displacement of the
cart is equal to all right i'm
integrating winter after time so tell me
what my period function is
I looks good
thank you
use my second integration so it's my
second consoling now I've got this
expression now interestingly i noticed
unlike say this particular value which
is like they they gave that to me but
however that she told me where the car
is in space they just told me where it
is relative to this guy so that means I
get to choose I can put it anywhere I
like what do you think would be a
reasonable value to choose how about
making the car's original position the
origin okay so i might add that on to my
diagram because i'm deciding that now so
i'm going to say let the car begin let
the car initially be at zero okay so
initially across these time zero that
means when you put t equal 0 into all of
these things they're all going to vanish
way which leaves you with zero that's
what I'm defining as the initial
position equals c2 so this constant I'm
just making it 0 and that's why it's a
convenient choice does that make sense
so far yeah so therefore here's my
displacement function for the car I'm
going to put yeah that's fine
oh yeah
right okay you've been begging me right
we're now we've got everything for the
car everything that I can know about the
car I know it i've got an acceleration
velocity and displacement now it's time
to look at the truck okay so just like
before what would you like me to do in
terms of writing some expressions and
all that kind of thing for example what
would you like me to say about this
there is no acceleration on the truck
right that's kind of a problem that's
why we're trying to overtake him right
so if there's no acceleration on the
truck that's nice but in fact I kinda
didn't need to know that why didn't just
say it rather because I already know
like without integration that adds time
zero this is the velocity of the truck
velocity of the truck and it's constant
okay so i could have gotten there by
differentiation if I wanted to but this
is just for the sake of completeness
remember we're still not sure where to
go over okay now have a look at this
avast ye the truck is capital v think
about what we've already done what would
you let me do next
hmm so I'm coming out I'm going to
integrate it in I think that's a great
idea now I've got two reasons why I'm
going to do that number one I kinda
don't know what else to do like I'm
looking I'm looking for coolers to hang
on to okay secondly this should make
sense I want to be able to connect this
displacement with this displacement does
that make sense I need them to be able
to talk to each other what that means
I've got this equation just need the
other one right so I'm going to go I'm
gonna integrate one last time right
capital v it's a constant so what
happens when i integrate by our final
answer thank you what a relief I don't
need to integrate anymore some people
like just did do it okay um what can I
do with this they don't need to be a
little more thoughtful here you remember
when we got to the displacement function
for the car you will like well you know
I can put the car wherever I like so I
just said let's make it start at the
origin okay but now that you fixed this
position now you know something about
this position right if that's zero then
where's this yeah good I've been given
this distance right so i can say but
initially course
when time equals 0 the displacement of
the track according to my scheme I
defined it I said where the origin was
he is going to be seen and you can see
in much the same way before this term is
going to disappear when I sub in T
equals 0 so therefore I now have an
expression for these two in relation to
each other ok you've done really well
I've got all the equations I need and
now I need to put them together in some
way to get to remember this is what I'm
after this is actually a normal and I
can work it out in terms of all these
constants that I've got ok now I want
you to come back to these red guys
remember these red guides the
acceleration of the car is what is going
to help me to cover this distance right
cover this distance how long do I have
to cover that distance well how long do
I have to cover that distance ah I know
how long I have to cover this because
look this truck right it's going to
travel that distance and that speed does
that make sense I've gotta cover cover
this distance the truck rather has to
cover this distance at that speed right
so time is distance on speed right
another way you could say that is well
where is the truck going to be where is
the truck going to be over here like
what cordon is this remember i define
the origin so this is c plus L right so
if you wanted to do it algebraically
rather than just like reasoning from
this picture i could say truck reaches
over taking away
when this displacement X track is equal
to yeah that whole distance right c plus
L from the origin c plus oh but I
already have a displacement function for
that guy that's VT plus c you can see
that these things are cancelling and
there is the L on V that you just told
me about right distance over the speed
okay now remember okay we said that's
how long the trucks going to take to
move and the car's got to say no time to
cover how far that distance right okay
so when does the car at what time does
the car hit that spot answer at that
time and that spot is c plus L right so
where are we going to take those two
things that time and that displacement
where am I going to put them in I want
to put them into here right at that
particular time you just told me that we
just worked down I want the displacement
of the car to be there right c plus L
okay so you see all of this work here
now we're going to use it so if you want
to in a word this all I say the truck
reaches the overtaking Lane wind etc the
car also reaches the overtaking way
at that same time T equals L on vid we
want them to arrive simultaneously sir I
can now say alright the displacement of
the car it should be at c plus l that's
where the overtaking Lane is yep that's
equal to what
it's that guy right hey Carl remember I
don't know what that is on to but I know
all the time bits right all the time
it's so there's the time so that's L on
v square let's c plus V times l MV yeah
what are you thinking look okay let's
tidy this up a little bit have a look
what happens to that last product on the
end ok cancel cancel but now that you've
got an L there it also cancels with the
left hand side so cancel and some ok so
now remember what am I going for what am
i aiming at I want the acceleration of
the car and all that other stuff is just
constants of whatever description ok so
if I were to put this all together in
one go the acceleration of the car is
going to be okay I already go see there
i'm going to multiply by 2 i'm also
going to multiply by v square and then
i'm going to divide by square ok